en este vídeo vamos a aprovechar lo que
ya sabemos sobre el modelo de oferta y
demanda agregada y la curva de phillips
y vamos a conectar estas ideas primero
la curva de phillips esta es la típica
curva de phillips para una economía la
alta inflación está asociada con un bajo
desempleo el alto desempleo se asocia
con una baja inflación pero realmente
podemos ver esta curva como la curva de
phillips a corto plazo la curva de
phillips a corto plazo podríamos estar
en diferentes puntos de esta curva en
diferentes momentos de un ciclo
económico pero también podríamos
introducir una idea conocida como curva
de phillips a largo plazo que se basa en
la tasa natural de desempleo de esta
economía así que digamos que la tasa
natural de desempleo para esta economía
es de 6% entonces nuestra curva de
phillips a largo plazo sería simplemente
una línea vertical justo aquí curva de
phillips a largo plazo ahora porque es
una línea vertical bueno esto significa
que en el largo plazo nuestra tasa
natural de s
leo es de 6 % independientemente de cuál
sea la tasa de inflación entonces si
estamos parados en la intersección de
estas dos curvas eso significa que
nuestra economía en este momento está
operando con pleno empleo si nuestro
desempleo fuera más bajo que esto
tendríamos un sobrecalentamiento de la
economía en algún grado y si el
desempleo fuera más alto entonces
tendríamos una brecha de producción
negativa pero como conectamos estas
ideas con la demanda agregada y la
oferta agregada bueno dibujemos nuestra
curva de oferta agregada a largo plazo y
lo haremos justo en la intersección de
nuestras curvas de demanda y oferta
agregada de corto plazo porque quiero
mostrar una economía que está operando a
su máximo potencial así que esta es
nuestra oferta agregada a largo plazo y
una vez más es una línea vertical porque
a largo plazo independientemente del
nivel de precios tenemos una cierta
producción para esta economía que es
sostenible entonces este es nuestro
pleno empleo voy a escribir de punto a
punto
es nuestra producción de pleno empleo
cualquier cosa por encima de eso es
insostenible según la situación
estructural de la economía en este
momento y algo menos que eso significa
que tienes una brecha de producción
negativa pero ahora pensemos qué pasaría
si comenzamos a cambiar las curvas qué
pasaría si tuviéramos un choque de
demanda negativa entonces nuestra curva
de demanda agregada cambiaría a la
izquierda bueno en ese mundo puedes ver
que tu precio de equilibrio llamaré a
esta demanda agregada a sub 2 nuestra
nivel de precios 2 y nuestra nueva
producción de equilibrio para nuestra
economía sub 22 ver que los dos son
menores
ahora tenemos una brecha de producción
negativa pero a que correspondería esto
en nuestras curvas de philips bueno
cuando tienes una brecha de producción
negativa es probable que tengas un mayor
desempleo y los cambios en la curva de
demanda agregada serían movimientos a lo
largo de la curva de phillips de corto
plazo
así que vamos a movernos a lo largo de
la curva de phillips a corto plazo y
vamos a tener un mayor desempleo porque
tenemos una brecha de producción
negativa entonces podríamos llegar a ese
punto y llamaré a ese punto sub dos así
que pasamos de una situación en la que
antes teníamos un 6% de desempleo y
digamos que teníamos un 3% de inflación
a un mundo donde quizás ahora tenemos no
sé dedicamos 9% de desempleo y ahora
tenemos un 2% de inflación y podría ser
al revés
digamos que comenzamos desde nuestra
curva de demanda agregada original y
tenemos un choque de demanda positivo
por lo que ahora podríamos ir a esta
curva demanda agregada 3 y aquí nuestro
nivel de equilibrio de precios es más
alto se llama ps3 y nuestra producción
de equilibrio tenemos una brecha de
producción positiva entonces aquí
tenemos ye sub 13 y eso correspondería
si tenemos una brecha de producción
positiva eso significa que tenemos un
desempleo muy bajo
tal vez un desempleo insosteniblemente
bajo entonces podríamos estar aquí tal
vez así que esta podría ser una
situación en la que nuestra tasa de
desempleo digamos que es de no sé el 4%
y ahora nuestra inflación podría ser
digamos que de 4% también y sucede algo
interesante cuando comienzas a tener una
inflación cada vez más alta esto puede
resultar en que las personas tengan
mayores expectativas de precios y
mayores expectativas de inflación y si
la gente tiene expectativas más altas
para la inflación entonces podrían
cobrar más por un cierto nivel de
producción digamos que en este nivel de
producción las personas podrían querer
tener un nivel de precios más alto en
este nivel de producción las personas
podrían querer tener un nivel de precios
más alto y así podría cambiar nuestra
oferta agregada de corto plazo hacia
arriba o podrías decir a la izquierda
entonces esta es nuestra oferta agregada
de corto plazo sub 3 ahora cuando la
oferta agregada de corto plazo se
desplaza hacia la izquierda en esta
situación
observen que volvemos a nuestra
producción de pleno empleo pero nuestro
nivel de precios ahora es mucho mayor
ahora que correspondería a eso aquí
bueno cuando tienes un cambio en las
curvas de oferta agregada de corto plazo
es un realidad llevaría a un cambio en
tu curva de phillips de corto plazo pero
de qué manera cambiaría bueno otra
manera de pensar en esto al igual que en
un nivel dado de producción hubieras
esperado un nivel de precios más alto y
debido a estas mayores expectativas de
inflación tendrías un nivel dado de
desempleo esperarías un mayor nivel de
inflación
así que nuestra curva se movería hacia
arriba o digamos hacia la derecha
entonces ahora nuestra curva de phillips
de corto plazo se vería así y le llamaré
sub 3 y tal vez podemos volver a este
punto bueno por cierto si estuviéramos
en esta producción en pleno empleo
entonces estaríamos operando en esta
tasa natural de desempleo de nuevo pero
fíjense ahora nuestra inflación se ha
elevado aún más esto podría ser un 5% de
inflación
ahora lo último que tal vez te preguntes
es cuando cambian estas curvas de largo
plazo bueno ya hablamos de eso antes
cuando hablamos sobre la oferta agregada
a largo plazo y eso cambia si la
economía cambia estructuralmente de
alguna manera digamos que nuestras
fábricas son bombardeadas en una guerra
o algo así entonces la curva de oferta
agregada a largo plazo debería cambiar
hacia la izquierda y si adquiriéramos
una mejor tecnología o mejores formas de
organizarnos o más recursos podría
cambiar la curva hacia la derecha del
mismo modo si hay un cambio masivo en el
comercio mundial y tal vez las
habilidades de nuestros trabajadores ya
no sean tan valiosas en la economía
global esta curva de phillips a largo
plazo podría moverse hacia la derecha si
de repente fuéramos capaces o con el
tiempo pudiéramos lograr que la gente
tuviera más habilidades tal vez
tendríamos un desempleo fraccional
porque tendríamos mejor tecnología para
colocar a las personas bueno eso podría
cambiar esto a la izquierda hasta el
próximo vídeo